care again this time I'm just gonna camp
out I'm gonna wait until I see one of
the managers
so I'm gonna do should wait here I'll
sleep right oh you just say though just
gonna wait wait wait wait wait me
waiting
Oh
what are you doing watch yourself some
me it's okay I wait to shoot up big
shots around here I'm trying to go in I
got its big audition with this big boy
big shot lies yeah I know right where it
is I'm actually I was just taking a nap
because I'm one of their uh I'm an
actress and I I model it idea and I
think but I'm really are starving her no
I'm not longer hear this I wasn't
sleeping you can have it at a major
garlic I mean I'll show you exactly
where we have to go okay
here is it up here yeah that's appear
it's all on this floor yeah well know
what ago I've been here I work here you
you work here what are you just taking a
siesta something like that yes duh yes
John that's all ticking if there was a
few minutes siesta it's nice out so
funny it's Los Angeles and solder paste
so much in rent house burn yeah you know
if it's a cloudy I like five bucks back
on your rent really well you just gave
me a dollar yeah I mean you're making
money just letting dollar bill daughter
omegle sunglasses is he nice thanks i
wear them inside some people think I'm
important really part of my look oh wait
a minute yeah that's cool do you think
I'm important I blow I knew your sleep
on the ground so I mean it's a little
late to work that me but it's like if I
need to know you I'd say hell yeah okay
i figger semi-soft hey when the doors
open for at T there we go k posh why ok
this guy is disguise the biggest casting
director in the valley I always just go
Dali which sounds like it's really big
this is the biggest guy in hot ok i wish
i could get up but I can film please you
I want you to be a boy status who are
you hi i just seen I just seems he's my
friend I'm sorry you can't be in here
Sam is gonna show me how to be fine ok
not to be funny listen I promise you I
swear to you i I've been camping outside
ok all right so Steve Jobs walks into a
bar and he's all like I got a big mac ok
he's like you know I know that you
really are excited about the SDK coming
out for the iphone are you gonna make
some apps she it's a it's a it's a genre
that hasn't really been
she's doing hun tak Sam tell me that
didn't happen all right exam I want you
to be funny please just room what's the
matter are you gonna draw this is new
carpeting I just had to share this rug
shampooed god oh my gosh all right Tim
let's deal with her later I want you to
give me a minute funny ready go I have
weird hobbies not to go on interviews
for jobs I really do you all think Steve
Jobs you'll say it's like really know
your plate why do you want weren't is
this guy I'll be like [__] i love
banging high school chicks in this place
roja good that I don't know your high
school chicks I love Mexican uh-huh I
love Mexican specially when they're on
YouTube [__] you ever watch that dude
those videos all those with the shirts
honest we're not each other that one bro
yes did you hear that did you hear that
that's how you do comedy you're okay you
regain consciousness look you don't just
yell out Steve Jobs and iphone all right
it's steve jobs whatever it is I don't
want you look get out of my office
that's a great big shame don't even call
me back yeah get her out of here juggle
she just be jobs does that make me laugh
okay you see jobs security get this
woman I have no do my phone now can't
get out of here it's just the round
sample cares about I rock so hard you
just like send me an email like when you
get your call back cuz i can pay here I
you know I get a call back cuz i won't
go you back so you don't ruin my next
audition I hate you good you know i mean
i love you surf the internet with me
yeah let's go surf what